[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه الساعه
ضمن ترقيتنا المستمره للانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه 2022 انها السادسه مساءا
بالتوقيت الساحل الشرقي الامريكي بعض
مراكز الاقتراع في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
بدات بالاغلاق بالفعل الان ااا مراكز في
ولايتي انديانا وكنتاكي بدات في الاغلاق
اذا بانتظار بدايه الفرز وكذلك ظهور
النتائج الاوليه من بعض المناطق تذهب الى
صور مباشره الان همم بدء عمليه فرز
الاصوات بعد اغلاق اذا صناديق الاقتراع
لدينا كذلك في كلورادو في فرجينيا كذلك
وكليب لاند وهايو كمان نتابع اذا هذه
الصور
مش هيلعب معكم اذا همم في اوهايو على ما
يبدو انه عمليه الاقتراع ما تزال مستمره
كما نتابع كولورادو ايضا همم ونتابع ايضا
عمليه فرز على ما يدل الاصوات في كليفلاند
على العموم ما نعلمه انه في الولايات بعض
الولايات في الساحل الشرقي في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بدات في اغلاق اذن مع
الموعد الرسمي مع السادسه مساء بتوقيت
الساحل الشرقي الامريكي
انديانا وكنتاكي اذا اجزاء منها مكاتب
اقتراح فيها اذا بدات في الاغلاق هو على
ان تبدا عمليه الفرز اذا اتباعا كما نتابع
هذه الصور ولقطات من مختلف الولايات
الامريكيه بث مباشر اذا من همم كلورادو
فيرجينيا وكليب لاند اوهايو
[موسيقى]
هناك اذا ااه ربما ال ال لحظات الاخيره او
الوقت المتبقي لعمليه الاقتراع وكذلك في
كولورادو على ما يبدو بدايه عمليه الفرز
كذلك كما ااا علمنا ان هذا اليوم طبعا هو
ليس يوم عطله بالنسبه للامريكيين
ويعني هم يستمر في هدايا عملهم بشكل طبيعي
وفي نفس الوقت يتوجهنا الى مكاتب الاقتراع
التي بدات تغلق الان في ولايات الساحل
الشرقي الامريكي كان هناك اقبال كبير على
هذه الانتخابات النصفيه التي يختار فيها
الامريكيون كل اعضاء مجلس النواب الامريكي
واكثر من همم ثلث عدد المقاعد في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي اضافه الى حكام بعض
الولايات الامريكيه واا بعض الحكام
المحليين والمناصب المحليه كذلك العديد
للولايات الامريكيه وهناك صراع كبير محمود
بين الحزبين الجمهوري بقى الديموقراطي
الارقام تشير الى حوالين 140 امريكي قاموا
بالادلاء باصواتهم ان كان بشكل مباشر او
ان كان عن طريق البريد والتصويت المبكر
اذا المشاهدين هذا ما نراقبه في هذه
الساعه اذا اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع ومراكز
الاقتراع في الولايات الساحل الشرقي
الامريكي نتبعها تباعا افاده استطاعات
امريكيه بان الناخبين هم غيره راضيين عن
اداء الرئيس
الاتحاد وان 70% من الناخبين لا يرغبون
بيترشح بيض لولايه يعتبرون ان الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه مهدده كما اعتبارا ان الوضع
الاقتصادي في امريكا اسوء من وضعه قبل
عامين فاشرت الاستطلاعات الى ان ثمانيه من
اصل 10 ناخبين هم غيره راضين على ذلك
الاقتصاد الامريكي كما ان ثلاثه من اصل 10
ناخبين كان للتضخم اولويه لهم في تصويبهم
وبحسب استطلاعات فان تسعه من اصل 10 ناخذ
بين الامريكيين لا يعتبرون الهجره غير
الشرعيه ملفا مهما ولا يعطون اهميه لملف
السلاح
اما في ولايه اريزونا فاكد مسؤولون في
مقاطعه ماريو كوبا ان ما يقرب من 20% من
مواقع الاختراع تعاني من مشكلات مع الات
الجدوله بعد ساعات فقط من افتتاح الاقتراع
في يوم الانتخابات النصفيه وقال رئيس مجلس
المشرفين في المقاطعه ان مشكله ظهرت عندما
حاول الناخبون اجراء اقتراعهم من خلال اله
الجدوله ولم يتمكنوا من القيام بذلك بنجاح
مشيرا الى ان الفنيين يعملون على حل
المشكله في اسرائيل
اما كاري ليك المرشحه لمنصبي حاكم ولايه
اريزونا فاعربت عن استيائها من الخلل
الفني الذي اصاب عمليه التصويت في الولايه
وتعاهدت كاري اليك بحل كل مشاكل التصويت
حاله فوزها بالملزق
وتلخص الانتخابات مشاهدينا على منصب
الحاكم في ولايه اريزونا مشهد الانقسام
السياسي الامريكي حيث تخوض مرشحه جمهوريه
مدعومه من قبل الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
على الانتخابات مقابله مرشحه اخرى هي
الديمقراطيه يدعمها الرئيس الامريكي
الاسبق باراك اوباما واعداء ترامب في
الحزب الجمهوري
في صحراء اريزونا تجره واحده من اكثر
معارك انتخابات التجديد النصفي تنافسيه
على منصب الحاكم بين الجمهوريه كيرليك
والديمقراطيه كيتي وبينهما الكثير من
الاستقطاب
هي نجمه الحزب الجمهوري الجديده اختارها
ترامب بنفسه لخوض السباق وتتبنى خطابه
بتزوير انتخابات عام 2020 بكل قوه
انا السيده
[تصفيق]
لمنصب نائب الرئيس على بطاقه ترامب اذا
قرر خوض سباق عام 2014
[موسيقى]
السقف نظام
النائبه الجمهوريه التي تشارك في تحقيقات
اقتحام الكبتل وتسببت ترامب في خسارتها
الانتخابات التمهيديه لهذا السبب تدعمه
ايضا يدعمها النائب الجمهوري ادم كنزنجر
الذي يشارك في تحقيقات الكابتل ووفر على
نفسه اهانه خساره الانتخابات التمهيديه
باعلانه عدم الترشح مجددا
استطلاعات الراي لم تحسمه هويه الفائز في
سباق حاكم اريزونا افضليه بسيطه للغايه
للمرشحات الجمهوريه تدعمها انتقادات
للمرشحات الديمقراطيه التي ترفض اجراء
مناظره ويؤكد معارضها انها خائفه من احراج
علني
نتابع المشهد الانتخابيه في هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه اذا من الشرق والغرب
الامريكيين مع
مراسلاتنا ناديه البلبيسي من واشنطن
سليمان من نيفادا مرحبا بكم معنا في هذه
الساعه اذا ابدا معك ناديه مراكز اقتراح
في الساحل الشرقي اذا بدات في
الاغلاق ماذا نراقب وماذا ننتظر
نراقب ما يسمى بالاكزت بول تعطينا مؤشر عن
توجه الناخبين خلال الساعتين القادمتين
سيكون لدينا ربما صوره اوضح عن مجلس
النواب مجلس الشيوخ قبل قليل كان هناك خبر
بان هناك ست مقاطعات في ولايه جورجيا قررت
الاستمرار في التصويت بقرار من المحكمه
بالسماح للمواطنين بالتصويت خارج الساعات
طبعا المحدده نسبه الاقبال عاليه جدا
تحدثنا عن 70% وهذي نسبه غير مسبوقه
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه عاده لا تتجاوز 62%
تقريبا في احسن احوال 65% هذا يعني بين
الامريكيين همم جزء منهم ربما الذين
سيصوتوا لصالح الجمهوريين يرون بان البلاد
تسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ والذين سيصوتوا
حزبيا للديموقراطيين يريدون الدفاع عن
مبدا الديمقراطيه الذي تحدث عنه الرئيس
لكن البيت الابيض اعتقد بانه يهيئ نفسه او
يتهيا نفسيا لقبول خسارتي في مجلس النواب
وكما قال الرئيس اليوم ستكون سنوات صعبه
امامه لانه المجلس سيعطل اي تشريعات يمكن
ان يقوم بها ويقوم بعكس حتى بعض التشريعات
التي انجزها ومن هنا كانت تحذير بانه
ضروره التصويت من قبل الناخبين الذين
ينتمون حزبيا الديمقراطيه في قضيه مجلس
النواب تحديدا بعد قليل ناديه نذهب الى
الغرب الامريكي لتسليمان معنا من هناك
مباشره همم انتم في الغرب الامريكي ما
يزال همم الكثير من الوقت لاغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع الصوره لديك وكذلك همم هل اتضحت
قصه الخلل الفني في اريزونا كذلك
نعم في اريزونا امم نسبه الاقبال على
الانتخابات بلغت قبل نصف ساعه من الان
حوالي 35 الى 40% ومن المتوقع ان تتخطى ال
55% ااا بعد ثلاث ساعات من الان عندما
تغلق صناديق الاقتراع وبالتالي يكون تم
تسجيل رقم قياسي همم بالمشاركه بهذه
الانتخابات وكان ذلك متوقع صهيب خاصه بطول
الحشد الذي قام به الحزبين الجمهوري
والديكوراتي خاصه همم في اريزونا همم كان
هناك خلل بمقاطعه همم
حول جدول وقراءه جدول الانتخابات همم طلب
من الناخبين حينها ان يبقوا في هذه
المراكز ولا يتركها
وان همم يتاكد من احتساب اصواتهم قويه همم
طبعا هذا الموضوع اثار السياقه المرشحين
الجمهوريين ولكن همم حتى اللحظه
الانتخابات مستمره لم نسمع
بتسجيل همم اي شكاوى جديده فيما يتعلق
بجدوله همم الناخبين دعني صهيب فقط اشير
بانه همم تم تسجيل حوالي مليون و200,000
تصويت مبكر تم ارسال هذه البريد في
اريزونا وحدها همم وبالتالي هذا ايضا رقم
كبير نسبه للسنوات الفائته وحوالي 20% من
هذه من الاصوات التي شاركت في التصويت
المبكر واليوم همم هي من الاصوات الشابه
اي انها من المره الاولى التي تنتخب وهذا
مؤشر كبير ومهم في همم اريزونا تحديدا
فيما يتعلق بمجلس النواب الامريكي
المؤشرات ذاهبه باتجاها على ان
الديمقراطيين سيخسرون الاغلبيه في النواب
ااا ماذا تقول التوقعات بخصوص نانسي فلوسي
العدو اللدود للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ستغيب نانسي فلوسي عن المجلس الذي كانت
رمز ربما للحكم في رمز السلطه المركز
الثالث في الولايات المتحده بعد الرئيس
ونائب الرئيس لانه بالعاده عندما يخسر
الحزب الاغلبيه لن يكون هناك رئيس
الاغلبيه وهي كانت متحكمه في هذا المجلس
لفتره طويله حتى عندما كانت رئيسه للاقليه
فالان نانسي فلوسي بعد الهجوم على زوجها
والاعتداء على مبنى الكابيتال هي ترى بانه
حاله الوقت ربما للتقاعد همم وانها تريد
ان تترك حتى ربما قبل ان يعلن عن
الانتخابات يعني اليوم كان هناك معلومات
الليله قبل ظهور النتائج لكن بغض النظر
اعتقد انها ستغيب عن الساحه السياسيه التي
وجدت فيها منذ عقود تقريبا وكانت همم
مؤثره بشكل كبير في تمرير الكثير من
المشاريع
الرئيس في البيت الابيض وكما تعرف مجلس
النواب يعني الكثير من المشاغبات تحدث به
لانه صعب جدا ضبط 435 نائب كل نائب له
توجه خاص وخصوصا في الحزب الديمقراطي ما
بين التقدمين اليسريين وما بين الوسطين
المعتدلين وبالتالي استطاعت بالفعل ان
نانسي فلوس ان تكون مؤثره وهذا منصب لاحدا
لا يحسد عليه لكن اعتقد بانها همم لن
نراها بعد اليوم هذه السيده التي احتلت
هذا المنصب بجداره بحسب توصيف المراقبين
طبعا
الشخصيات همم اذهب اليك ريتا في همم
نيفادا اولي اسالك عن شخصيه برزت كذلك في
هذه الانتخابات النصفيه هي شخصيه كاريك
وهي مرشحه جمهوريه يدعمها ترامب بقوه همم
هل يعني ما سر هذا الدعم من قبل ترامب
واهم التصريحات لها كذلك وهل صحيح انه
يمكن ان تكون مرشحه لمنصب نائب الرئيس في
حاله رشح دونالد ترامب رسميا
همم
من يعتقد ذلك
اختيار كاريليك هو مثال يتمنظرنا الى
اختيارات الرئيس ترامب همم سالنا احد
الخبراء عن هذا الموضوع قال بانه ترامب
همم كما يحب ان يسمي نفسه بصانع الملوك هو
يبحث عن اتباع فقط
كاريك هي تمثل همم طبيعيه العمياء
ترامب فهي تردد كل العبارات بكل مناسبه
همم اولها تصوير الانتخابات الماضيه وتشكك
بفوز الرئيس
همم وتعهد همم متابعه هذا الموضوع مرارا
وتكرارا همم تحدث ايضا عن همم الاعلام
التي اطبعها الاعلام وانت تحاول نظريات
المعارض الماره التي يحاول الاعلام فرضها
ايضا يعني كل ما يؤمن به ترامب تؤمن به
كاريليك وتقول للعلم تحديدا في كل
المناسبه حتى في اليوم عندما قال بانها لم
تعترف بنتائج باي نتائج لهذه الانتخابات
هو نتيجه واحده وهي فوزيها وفوز المرشحين
الجمهوريين في هذه الانتخابات
التي تغلق اتباعا وتعطينا صوره كذلك على
النتائج الاوليه امامي هنا مؤشر اخر حوالي
باقي 38 دقيقه لاغلاق همم المراكز همم
مراكز اخرى جديده ضمن همم هذه المراكز
التي ستغلق همم يعني تقديريا كم تستغرق
عمليه ظهور النتائج ناديا
يعني ساعات اعتقد انه يمكن ان اتحدث
الساعه القادمه عن بعض المؤشرات التي قد
تعطينا ربما نافذه لمعرفه سيطره ال
الجمهوريين على المجلس لكن ربما بات الامر
محسوما يعني ما نريد ان نعرفه حجم هذه
السيطره هل نتحدث عن 20 او 28 مقعد او
نتحدث عن اغلبيه بسيطه جدا وبالتالي تصبح
حياه كيفن مكافي الذي دعامه وايضا الرئيس
ترامب قبل قليل وقال بانه يتطلع لان يكون
رئيسا لمجلس النواب طبعا بدل نانسي فلوسي
في حال سيطره الجمهوريين همم كيف المقاطع
في اذن وشخصيه جدليه احيانا يقترب من
الرئيس همم ترامب واحيانا ينتقده لكن ترام
كما قالت ريته هو يدعم هذه الشخصيات التي
لديها التبعيه كامله له وهو لا يخجل حتى
من الحديث على انه هو الذي يصنعها هؤلاء
الاشخاص وبالتالي يتوقع ولا ان تاما منهم
لكن كما ذكرت صهيب اعتقد بانه الساعات
القادمه سنعرف على الاقل في مجلس النواب
ليس مجلس الشيوخ لكن مجلس النواب اعتقد
سيكون لدينا صوره نوعا ما يمكن ان نقول من
خلالها بانه بالفعل استطاع الجمهوريون
السيطره على المجلس بانتظار ذلك سنبقى في
المتابعه معكما شكرا جزيلا لكما زميلتي
ناديه والدته من واشنطن العاصمه ومن نفعها
ونفادا هي اصعب بانتخابات لمجلس الشيوخ
مشاهدينا في التجديد نصفي للكونغرس
الامريكي وقد تقلب المجلس باكمله لصالح
احد الحزبين هذه الانتخابات تحكمها ابعاد
الاقتصاديه طبعا التضخم وشبح الركود
يهددان سيطره الديمقراطيين عليها
السياسه والاقتصاد عنصراني متلازمان
ويؤثران على بعضهم البعض هذا الامر لن
يكون بمنئا عن الانتخابات النصفيه في
الولايات المتحده
هنا نيفادا احدى ولايات الجنوب الغربيه
واشهر مدنها لاس فيغاس المعروفه بعاصمه
المتعه والترفيه في العالم والتي تعتبر
مصدر دخل اساسيا للمواطنين كما تعتمد
نيفادا ايضا على قطاع التعدين وصناعه
الالات وقطع غيار المحركات
عام 2020 ضرب فيروس كورونا العالم وكانت
نيفادا اكبر المتاثرين حيث اصبحت لاس
فيجاس الصاخبه صامته لترتفع بها معدلات
البطاله الى رقم قياسي لاكثر من 34% في
اكتوبر من الاعمده وما ان بدات في التحسن
حتى ضرب التضخم الولايات المتحده والعالم
فتاثرت الصناعه وبات شبح الركود على
الابواب واصبحت تمتلك معدل تضخم هو الاعلى
في البلاد
كل هذه العوامل جعلت الانتخابات النصفيه
في ولايه نيفادا تشهد منافسه شرسه على
مقعد مجلس الشيوخ حيث يتمتع الجمهوري
والمدعي العام السابق ادم لاكزالت بفراس
الفوز على كسر كورتيز ماستو اولي لاتينيه
تحصل على مقعد في مجلس الشيوخ عام 2016
ووفقا للاستطلاعات راي اجرتها صحيفه
واشنطن بوست القى الناخبون باللوم على
الديمقراطيين لسوء الاوضاع الاقتصاديه اما
في السباق على منصب الحاكم يتنافس الحاكم
الحالي ستيف سيسولاك اول حاكم ديمقراطيه
لنيفادا منذ 20 عاما ضد الجمهوري جون برده
عمده مقاطعه كلارك
عقد من الزمن لم يستطع الجمهوريون الفوز
بمقعد في مجلس الشيوخ في نيفادا لكن
الازمات الاقتصاديه قد تقلب المعادله في
الانتخابات المقبله
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نحن في هذه الساعه نتابع
معكم بدايه اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع خاصه في
الساحل الشرقي في انديانا وكذلك كنتاكي
ومع بدايه الاغلاق الرئيس جو بايدن يستخدم
تويتر كثيرا في هذه الساعات الاخيره اخر
تغريده له قبل تسع دقائق هو يقول مع بدايه
اغلاق بعض مراكز الاقتراع في بعض اجزاء
البلاد اذا كنت موجود الان في الطابور في
مركز اقتراعك همم فضع صوتك قبل ان يغلق
مركز الاقتراع ابقى في الخط او ابقى في
الطابور يقول رئيس في حفثه على التصويت
لان الناخبين مع بدايه اغلاق صناديق
الاقترا ايضا يقول للناخبين الامريكيين
همم اجعل صوتك مسموعا اذا هو ما زال رغم
انه عمليه التصويت قد وصلت الى نهايتها في
بعض المناطق خاصه في الساحل الشرقي
الامريكي هو ما زال يحث الناخبين كذلك على
ده باصواتهم والمشاركه بقوه في هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه همم يدخل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن اذا في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه وهو يضع حزمه في موقف صعب للغايه
شعبيه الرجل اخذه في التاكل والسبب
الرئيسي في هذا يعود الى الاقتصاد نقطه
ضعفه كبيره قبل الانتخابات انتقد بيض
قراره تكلاس بخفض انتاج النفط لذلك لانه
حاول افضل اسعار ليدخل الانتخابات بيده
ورقه الرابحه دون الالتفات الى الحاجه
الحقيقيه للسوق ومصلحه الاقتصاد الحلبي
ازمه امريكا مع النفط بدات مع دخول
الجوبايدن المكتبه البيضاوي قرر الرئيس
السادس والاربعون وقفه منحي تراخيص
واذونات جديده للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في
الاراضي الفيدراليه مشكله اولى من صنع يد
الرئيس فاقمها بمشكله ثانيه قرار بضرب
مشروع انابيب كيستون الاستراتيجي مع كندا
الذي يستطيع نقل تقريبا نحو مليون برميل
يوميا الى ساحل خليج الولايات المتحده
اوقفه كما اشرنا ايضا بعد ان اجازه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ضمن استراتيجيه
ادارته لتعزيز امن الطاقه في امريكا
اكثر من ذلك قاوم بعد الضغوط التي مارستها
كندا على الولايات المتحده لاحياء خط
انابيب كيستون اكس ال تعويضا عن الامدادات
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات لكن لمشكله
النفط في الولايات المتحده جانب وسبب مزمن
ايضا
ليست كلها من صنع اخطاء بيضا الذي يعرف
عنه اصلا توجهه نحو الطاقات المتجدده
بموازاه استراتيجيه خفض الاستثمارات في
قطاع استخراج النفط وتكريره فالادارات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه في العقدين الماضيين
اهملت قضيه صيانه واستثمار مصافي تكرير
النفط
متلو بايدا يسر الديمقراطيون على
استراتيجيات تحديد سقف مرتفع لمواصفات
الوقود تتسبب بمشاكل في الامدادات وارتفاع
الاسعار بالطبع بالارقام ايضا تراجع عدد
المصافي 13 بالمئه خلال عشر سنوات رقم هو
الادنى
ارتفاع الاسعار في الولايات المتحده يعود
الى نقص القدره على تحويل النفط الى وقود
وبالتالي تراجع المعروض في السوق الداخليه
بالارقام شكل الهامش بين اسعار النفط
الخام والمنتجات المكرره نحو 20 دولارا
نقلتها الحرب الاوكرانيه الى عتبه السبعين
دولارات
عامل اخر يضع بثقله المعنوي العلاقه
السيئه بين بيض وشركات النفط الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يتهمون الرئيسه بالاضرار
بشركات النفط العملاقه واذ قال قدره
انتاجها بالضرائب المبالغه بها والقيود
القانونيه والتشريعيه اذا اضفنا الى سلسله
هذه المشاكل الداخليه عامل الطبيعه اعني
هنا الاعاصير التي تتسبب بتوقف مصافي
التكرير او تراجع قدرتيكر فيها ايضا يعود
انخفاض مخزون البنزين الى اغلاق المصافي
بحجه عدم ربحتها الكبيره لماذا لم تعد
مربحه بسبب القوانين البيئيه الصارمه
والضرائب كما اشعرنا فالمشكله اذا تقنيه
بحث لكنها لماذا اخذت هذا البعض والسجال
الذي وصل الى حد اتهام قرار اوبك كلاس
لا يتحمل بيض مسؤوليه اسعار الطاقه وفق
بلوبرج هناك عوامل عده متعلقه به لعب
الدورا مهما خصوماته لشركات النفط وتعهده
بوقف استخدام الوقود الاحفوري ضمن مجموعه
من العوامل الاخرى طبعا افقدت قدره السوق
طاقه الامريكيه على التعامل بمرونه مع
صدمه الاسعار
مع امتحان انتخابين لولايته في الثامن من
نوفمبر
سلاح سياسي بوجه سلعه حيويه اقتصاديه بحث
ليس لامريكا فحسب بل للعلم
اذا مشاهدينا وفي هذه الساعه اذا المزيد
من مراكز الاقتراع ستغلق اذا امام
الناخبين بعد قليل عند السابعه بتوقيت
ساحل الشرقي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اي بعد حوالي نصف ساعه من الان
او اقل جورجيا انديانا كنتاكي ساوت
كارولين وفيرجينيا ستغلق مراكز الاقتراع
فيها ومع بدايه الاغلاق هذه حتى الرئيس
بويدا قبل قليل المزيد من الناقبين على
الادلاء باصواتهم في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه
وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه دكتور وليد همم في هذه الساعات
الاخيره بالنسبه للساحل الشرقي على الاقل
هناك توقعات بان مجلس النواب يتجه الى ان
يكون
للجمهوريين في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه ما
الذي يعني ذلك
هذا هو الاتجاه فقط للمشاهدين الكرام
الارقام مهمه بعكس الانتخابات الرئاسيه
حيث يجب انتظار اكتمال الاصوات التي تسمح
للمرشح الرئاسي بان يقول انا وصلت الى هذه
الاصوات الارقام في مجلس النوابات مجلس
النواب هي
435 يعني 217 اذا وصلت الارقام الى 217
زائد واحد يعني يكون الاكثريه لمجلس نواب
بالنسبه لمجلس الشيوخ هل هي مئه شيخ 51
نعطيهم الاكثريه الثانيه هي انه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كما راينا في المره
الماضيه ممكن انه النتائج تتاخر يومين
ثلاثه احيانا اسبوع او كما حدث بفلوريدا
همم
همم يعني اسابيع بينما هنا في هذه
الانتخابات لا ننسى انه قد تكون هنالك
مشاكل لناخذ مثل اريزونا او اماكن اخرى
ولكن يتم تخطيها اذا وصلت النتائج الى
الرقم المطلوب يقال انتصر جمهوريون او
ديمقراطيون ولكن هذه المشاكل سوف تعاد
تعيد الانتخابات نعم نعم اذا السيطره
جمهوريون على مجلس النواب على الاقل لا
ندري بالنسبه لمجلس الشيوخ هذا سيعني
تاثيرا كبيرا على الاداره يعني الاداره
اداره ملزمه بان تتفاوض مع مجلس النواب
مجلس النواب له كما يقال
المال هو يقرر الميزانيات وبالتالي على
البيت الابيض ان يتفاوض معهم نعم ربما نحن
في الاعلام العربي الدكتور وليد نركز على
الانتخابات رئيس ولكن هذه الانتخابات
حكام الولايات في امريكا ما مدى اهميتها
كذلك ولماذا نشاهد ترامب يعني يدعم مرشحين
جمهوريين بعينهم لمناصب في حكام الولايه
دون شك في الماضي انا عشت حوالي 32 سنه في
الاولاد احدى الامريكيه قليلا كنا نهتم
حتى هنا يعني الشرق اوسطيين الامريكيين
بموضوع الحكام لانه محليين يعني اكثريه
فلوريدا هي تقرر من هو الحاكم هذا لا لن
يؤثر على السياسه القوميه وكانت اقتصاديه
او او سياسيه او غيرها بالطبع لن يؤثر
اطلاقا انه النظرون على السياسه الخارجيه
تغيرت الامور منذ تقريبا الصراعات اوباما
ترامب
لانه الحكام باتم هم الذين يؤثرون على
سكان تلك الولايه واضرب مثلا كبيران الاول
والثوره ده والثاني هو التكساس يعني فلورا
ده هي كانت القلعه التي سمحت للحزب
الجمهوري ان يستمر بقوه وان يعود في هذا
الهجوم المعاكس همم في هذه المرحله النجم
عند جمهوريين هو ديسانتس الحاكم رانده
سانتوس ولهذا الحكام اليوم هم اهم من
مكانه في الماضي على الصعيد القومي شكرا
جزيلا
الخارجيه الامريكيه على هذه المشاركه معنا
في هذه التغطيه
ومشاهدينا نحن باقونا في مراقبه اغلاق
مكاتب الاقتراع في الساحل الشرق الامريكي
في هذه الساعه فاصل نواصل بعده الترقيات
قومه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام من جديد نتابع
من ولايه جورجيا التي تغلق فيها مراكز
الاقتراع بعد قليل بعد اقل من نصف ساعه
تحديدا من 20 دقيقه يصنف هناك في جورجيا
العديد من الناخبين في مدن ولايه جورجيا
مع عاصمتها
وتصنفون الجريمه ضمن اولوياتهم حتى ان
بعضهم اعتبرها القضيه رقم واحد بالنسبه
لهم واستجابه لهذا الاهتمام اصبحت الجريمه
وانتشر الاسلحه المحور الاساسيه في سباق
انتخابات الولايه حيث كانت حاضره بقوه في
المناظره الاخيره بين الحاكمه الجمهوريه
والمرشح الديمقراطيه لمصر الحاكم سبايسي
ابرامز وكذلك في مناظره المرشحين لمجلس
الشيوخ السيره الديمقراطيه رافا
ومنافسه الجمهوريه هيرش الوكر التفاصيل مع
حسين الطارق
قضيه الجريمه في ولايه جورجيا طلقه
اهتماما كبيرا من الناخبين فالتنقل في
احياء عده في مدن مثل اتلانتا ليس امنا
ومن المؤشرات على ذلك انتشار الشرطه
بكثافه في العديد من الشوارع
زياده العنف تلازم الحياه اليوميه لكثير
من سكان المدينه لهذا سيختارون المرشحين
الذين يتعاملون مع الموضوع بالحزم
جدا لانني ارغب في شعوري بالامان في
المدينه التي اعيش فيها وهذا مهم ايضا
بالنسبه لمن ساصور اريد ان اشعر انني
استطيع ان اعيش حياتي لان المدينه
والمسؤولين لا يخلقون مكانا امنا للعيش
فيه كويس
هذا الاهتمام وجعل الجريمه نقطه المحوريه
في سباق الانتخابات حيث اتهم المرشح
الجمهوري لمجلس الشيوخ هرش الواقع
السيناتور الديمقراطيه الحاليه رفاييل
وناق بالتعامل بلين مع الجريمه التي
يستخدمها الجمهوريون كورقت ضغط في حملاتهم
ضد الديمقراطيين في المقابلتهم
الديمقراطيه لمنصب الحاكم السيسي ابرامز
الحاكم الحاليه الجمهوريه
بانه اضعف قوانين الاسلحه وملا الشوارع
بها
في التعامل مع الجريمه من الجمهوريين عبر
الحد من الاسلحه التي تسبب ارتفاع
معدلاتها
وتريد ان تشعر بهذه البيئه اثناء وجودك
هنا لذا لكي نعطي اصواتنا للمرشحين من
المهم ان المعرفه خطتهم للتخلص من الجريمه
في اتلانتا
موضوع الحد من انتشار الاسلحه التي يسهل
اقتنائها ويامل مواطنون بوضع ضوابط لبيعها
سيكون ايضا من اسباب اختيار المرشحين
القادرين على توفير الامن في جورج
فيما يصلي طول الجمهوريون الضوء على
مخاوفهم من انتشار الجريمه ويحملونها
الديمقراطيين المسؤوليه عن ذلك يركز
الديمقراطيون في حملتهم على انهما يدعمون
سياسه اسلحه اكثر صرامه
مرتبطان وفي جورجيا هما من اولويات
الناخبين الحسين الطاوضه قناه العربيه من
احد نوادي الرمايه ومتاجر الاسلحه في
ولايه جورجيا
[موسيقى]
متابع في هذه التغطيه منه دكتور ايمن غريب
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه يا دكتور
اهلا بك معنا نتحدث عن قضيه السلاح نتحدث
عن الركود عن التضخم الازمه الاقتصاديه
برايك ما هي القضيه الفيصل التي تهم
الناخب الامريكي وهي التي تجعله يصوت
للديمقراطيين او الجمهوريين في هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه
القضيه الاقتصاديه قضيه الجيب قضيه
الاسره او رب الاسره والاب والام على
القيام بدفع
المبالغ التي يحتاجون اليها مثلا تعليم
ابنائهم اذا كان يرسلون ابنائه من ان الى
مدارس خاصه او الى الجامعه القدره على
شراء الحاجيات الاساسيه
وبالتالي فان القضيه الاقتصاديه شراء
البنزين شراء الحاجيات الاساسيه
الغذاء كلها نعم قبل الانتخابات النصفيه
قرار اوبك بلس بخفض الانتاج باليونير
يوميا وهو يعني ما اثار حفيظه الاداره
الامريكيه واعتبرته قرارا سياسيا السعوديه
قالت انه هذا القرار اقتصادي بحث وجاء
بناء على دراسه مقتضيات السوق برايك يعني
كيف اثر القرار على هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه كيف سيؤثر وكيف ستؤثر نتيجه هذه
الانتخابات على تعاطي الاداره الامريكيه
مع ملف اوبيك بلاس بعد الانتخابات النصفيه
ساهم هذا القرار في مساعده الجمهوريين الى
حد ما وذلك لان الجمهوريين بداوا يوجهوا
الانتقادات طبعا هي لم تاتي يعني كا من
شيء بحيث ان كان هناك بعض الانتقادات
لقياده الرئيس
ورفضه منح مثلا تصاريح ورخص لشركات النفط
صغيره والكبيره للقيام بالتلقيط في
الاراضي الحكوميه في في المياه
الحدوديه الاقليميه الامريكيه وايضا الوقت
الخط من كندا الى الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي فان هذه كانت من بين الانتقادات
التي اضعفت الرئيس لان الرئيس كان يقول
بانه الوضع هو على ما يرام الوضع
الاقتصادي يتحسن البطاله تتقلص همم لدينا
عدد اكبر من العاملين ولكن ارتفاع اسعار
النفط عندما وصلت بعد هذه الاصل الاسعار
الجالون الى حوالي سبع او ثمانيه دولارات
الديمقراطيه همم سمعت الدكتور ادمن هذه
صور قبل قليل لظهور الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب اذا في ولايه فلوريدا
همم اذا في احد التجمعات اذا على ما يبدو
طيب لا اعلم اذا كان هناك صوت او بوسع لا
نسمع صوت الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب لا
يوجد صوت اذا دكتور اذن غريب ساكتفي معك
بهذا القدر شكرا جزيلا لك على مشاركتك
معنا في هذه التغطيه
ومشاهدين هذه الانتخابات هي استفتاء على
ذلك الرجل انه جو بايدن رغم انه قال انها
ليست استفتاء عليه بل استفتاء على
الديمقراطيه في امريكا لكن في النهايه
تبقى نتيجه هذه الانتخابات كاشفه لراي
الامريكيين في ادارته حتى الان المزيد مع
طاهر بركه
[موسيقى]
انا
الرئيس السادس والاربعون للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عمري 80 عاما قضيت منها 50 عاما
في السياسه ولم ازل
في عهد اصبحت فاتوره جره الغاز في مطابخ
المواطنين ولتر البنزين في سياراتهم
واضاءه غرف نومهم تقدم تماما كما يفعله
الذين يقوتا يوميا ليبقى عيني على حقيبه
النوويه واصبعيه على الزناد
في الخريف العمر الذي يصادف منتصف ولايه
الاولى اصل الى مكتب البيضاوي في الجناح
الغربي من البيت الابيض كل يوم لاجد كيف
راك ما طاقم ملفات البلاد الساخنه والعالم
الاكثر سخونه وبعدما استكملت مواجهه
كورونا وتداعيته الاقتصاديه خفضت تضخم
الذي لا يزال مرتفعا واعدت البطاله الى
مستويات ما قبلنا واقريت مع الكونجرس
قوانين ب 100 مليارات دولارات لكل منها
كقانون رقائق الالكترونيه والعلوم قانون
المناخ والصحه خطه تحفيز الاقتصاد وخطه
اعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه
غير ان كثيرا من هذه القوانين لما تاتي
بعد ثمارا سريعا اقطفها في انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه التي ما فتات تعكر صفها
قضايا الاجهاض والمخدرات والسلاح المتفرد
والنظام الصحي وتلك الجندريه منها
صحيح انني كبرت وقد اتعثر على سلم طائره
وهو ما يتوسله دونالد ترامب سبيلا للهجوم
الانتخابيه عليه ولكني اظل الشغوف فاب
بقياده السيارات بسرعه جنونيه ولو كان في
شبابي صحيح انني كبرت وحصل ان اخطات مرارا
في خطاباتي ونسيت اسماء وخالفت مراسم
واختلطت علي امور وهو مابات الجمهوريون
يعيرونني به ايضا وانا ابن المؤسسه
التشريعيه العريقه والشهير بالخطابه
والفصاحه وسن القوانين رغم مشكله التلعكم
عندي
يشار اليه عاده كفاني رئيس كاثوليكي بعد
جون كينيدي الذي اغتيل وكنائب رئيس لاول
رئيس اسود وكول رئيس تنوب عنهم امراه رغم
ما تسمعونه من اتهامات بمخالطات لصيقه
للنساء وبين ملف محلي افرغ منه واخر دولي
يبقى عالقا تطفو على سطح ذاكرتي صور عائله
صغيره
زوجه الاولى ليليا وسوره ابنتي وهما
اللتان توفيت في حادث سير بعيدا انتخابي
في مجلس الشيوخ وصوره بوم وهو ابن الذي
خسر معركته مع السرطان عندما كنت نائما
للراس وسوره هانتر نجل الاخر المتورط
بسمعه سيئه والاتهامات فساد في اوكرانيا
انا جو بايدن
نعم سيكتب التاريخ عن عهدي انني تسببت
بفوضه في افغانستان عندما سحبته جندي
ايفاء لهم بوعودي ولكنه سيكتب ايضا انني
قتلت ايمن الظواهري دون ان ارسل له جنديا
واحدا على الارض واوروبا العجوز مثلي
والتي انحدر شخصيا منها منقسمه وضعيفه رغم
انني وقعت على توسيع ليشمل فنلندا والسويد
من اجل حمايتها بين انني احكم في وقت يبزغ
فجر اقطاب عالميه رائده جديده عينها على
ما تعتبره انها القوميه قد تبدا بروسيا في
اوكرانيا ولا تنتهي بالصيني
قوى الامر الواقع النووي ككوريا الشماليه
او الطامحه كائران والتي فشلت في اعادتها
الى الاتفاق النووي يقول للتاريخ ان هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه عاده ما تكون استفتاء
على الرئيس وماضيه ويقول للحاضر انها قد
تكون استفتاء على الرئيس السابق ومستقبله
السياسي اما مستقبل السياسي انا فربما لم
يعد جمبني بالكثير انا جو بعيده
وتصويت والحزب الجمهوري في ولايه الاسكا
هو احدث مثال على الخلاف بين قاده
جمهوريين مثل زعيم الاقليه
وحلفاء الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب حيث
انتقد الحزب الجمهوري مهاجمتها لكيلي
لشباكا المرشحه المعتمده من قبلهم للمقعد
بمجلس الشيوخ
حماوه السباق الانتخابي في الاسكا قسمت
صفا الجمهوريين انفسهم في اكبر الولايات
الامريكيه واكثرها بروده وجددت صراعا لم
يهدا بين الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وزعيم الاقليه بمجلس الشيوخ متماكونال
بشكل غير مباشر هذه المره فازمه الفيل
الاحمر هناك اكثر تعقيدا مع دخول الحزب
الجمهوري الانتخابات النصفيه
عن مقعد الاسكا بمجلس الشيوخ ولهما سنه
الحاليه لزمور كاوسكي التي تحاول انتزاعه
ولايه رابعه
اكلت شباكه وثانيا بالرئيس السابق الذي
يدعمها
بتسير حمله الناشطه ضد مرقصكي بعد تصويتها
لادانته على خلفيه اقتحام انصاره للكونغرس
وسخريتها من مواصفه جمهوريون حينها
بالتجمع السياحي
والمشاركه بحمله واعلانات هجوميه على
الشباكه وصفت بالمثيره للانقسام والمضلله
فالاعلانات التهامتها بالاحتيال وهدري ام
والده فعل الضرائب ما دفع الجمهوريين
لانتقاد استهداف ماكونا لمرشحتهم المعتمده
في السباق ونومه على تقديم الدعم المالي
لمنافستها من خلال صندوق القياده بمجلس
الشيوخ
تقديم مرشحتين واكثر عن الحزب نفسه للوصول
للانتخابات العامه خاصيه يتميز بها نظام
التصويت في الاسكا الذي يطيح للناخبين
ترتيب المرشحين في مجلس الشيوخ حسب
الافضليه
[موسيقى]
هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن التغطيه ما تزال
مستمره حوالي خمس دقائق تفصلنا الان على
اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع في جورج
نبيل وابراهيم بدر يتابعان معكما التغطيه
الخاصه بالانتخابات المصريه 2022 في
الساعه المقبله
[موسيقى]